shocking statistics of hardship faced by
almost a quarter of the e use 500
million citizens caught in a poverty
trap worsened by the economic crisis the
last count 40 million people suffering
from severe material deprivation 25
million children at risk of poverty or
social exclusion four million people
homeless despite vast numbers of vacant
houses today MEP s endorsed proposals
for an aid program designed to help
Europe's most needy over the next seven
years it's a small program it's only
three and a half billion euro but it is
the only program that the European Union
has that specifically reaches out to
people who are completely marginalized
who are homeless who are suffering from
food deprivation who are say who are
suffering the consequences maybe of
family and child poverty MEP succeeded
in increasing the fund by a billion
euros to 3.5 billion euros in widening
the scope to finance social inclusion
measures and for the first time in
including all Member States in the
program those countries like Greece like
Spain like Hungary that where the system
is not working for poor people anymore
at all while the relatively richer
countries should really be trying to get
people structurally out of poverty in
the short term in some other countries
that is really not an option so we need
to reserve food aid for these countries
where people are literally hungry
without it the program known as feed or
the fund for European aid to the most
deprived becomes operational immediately
and replaces a fund set up almost 30
years ago to give Europe's most needy EU
surplus food supplies